deserted streets in the city of rayleigh
after chinese authorities imposed a
lockdown
the city on the border with myanmar has
seen a sudden rising cases in recent
days
mass testing is now underway to try and
halt the spread
which is thought to originate across the
border
inside myanmar itself the covert
situation is deteriorating quickly
but instability following the military
coup has meant testing and treatment
have almost ground to a halt medics have
been targeted by the military
because of their role in the civil
disobedience movement
and many have been forced into hiding
the public uh call of the doctors as
heroes heroes due to
our actions in the corporate pandemic
last year
but we have become criminals overnight
by the military in indonesia greater
transparency
but that has only revealed tens of
thousands of daily infections
oxygen supplies have run so low that
many hospitals have had to suspend
admissions
some patients now relying on private
suppliers to fill
much needed canisters for home care
we need oxygen because one of our family
members is experiencing breathing
difficulties
and we are running out of it that's why
i have to queue
we need it badly even in south korea a
country noted for its effective response
to covert 19
infections are reaching record levels
the government will uphold
existing social distancing rules for
another week and do our best to stop the
spread by taking extra disinfection
measures
new supplies of vaccine arriving in the
capital seoul
sent from israel across asia there's a
rush to secure and distribute vaccines
as quickly as possible
but with supplies limited it feels like
a race against time
as covert 19's delta variant swamps
asia in a fourth wave tony cheng al
jazeera
bangkok